ja das war nochmal unsere
zusammenfassung von der debatte gestern
im deutschen bundestag mit einigen
historischen ankündigungen von olaf
scholz dem bundeskanzler und dazu möchte
ich jetzt redet mit stefan kreutzberger
von der universität rostock dort sind
sie ja zeithistoriker zeithistoriker
beschäftigen sich unter anderem mit der
zeit des letzten jahrhunderts ausgehen
dass letztes jahrhundert das schauen wir
doch mal in die 80er jahre zurück da
hatten wir ja schon mal so eine rüstung
debatte eine massive aufrüstung debatte
damals mit bundeskanzler helmut schmidt
und der es am ende ja über seine eigene
partei gestolpert sehen sie da parallel
oder was war damals ganz anders
ich hoffe nicht dass ich parallelen sehe
nicht in dieser kritischen situation
aber der nato doppelbeschluss und dessen
umfeld 1979 und dessen umsetzung dann 19
82 83 dann unter helmut kohl sind ein
ganz gutes beispiel was es bedeutet wenn
die nato allianz in krisenzeiten eng
zusammenrückt und zusammensteht und auch
durchaus unpopuläre maßnahmen durchsetzt
wenn man sich vergegenwärtigt dass die
ganzen 70er jahre ja die zeiten der
neuen entspannung der neuen ostpolitik
gewesen sind und plötzlich am ende
dieser zeit aufrüstung
mittelstreckenraketen die jetzt auf dem
gebiet der bundesrepublik stationiert
werden sollen aber was ist denn damals
anders gewesen dass der kanzler damals
über diesen doppelbeschluss gestolpert
ist warum glauben sie ist heute nicht
mehr so einfach ja also es gestolpert
sie sagten dass gerade an seiner eigenen
partei schmidt ein ausgesprochener
realpolitiker gleichgewichts politiker
stolz wie scholz jetzt das ist sozusagen
das neue jetzt wieder was man so gar
nicht ohne weiteres erwartet hätte und
wenn ich jetzt von scholz als
sozialdemokraten scholz zurück blicke in
die 70er jahre schmid war immer auch als
als als als seeheimer vertreter des
seeheimer kreises jemand der sehr
realistisch an die sache herangegangen
ist und auch dann durchaus auch
gegenüber dem linken flügel seiner
eigenen partei aber auch gegenüber der
damaligen grundstimmung in der
westdeutschen öffentlichkeit
durchaus rückgrat bewies und zumindest
von der notwendigkeit dieser nachrüstung
überzeugt sei damit wieder im
mittelstreckenbereich ein gleichgewicht
hergestellt ist und man auf augenhöhe
mit der sowjetunion verhandeln kann und
das hat sich am ende auch materialisiert
michael gorbatschow ländern spätestens
seit 87 88 mit dem bmf abkommen im
mittelstreckenbereich 1 und das ist dann
der anfang vom ende natürlich auch
letztlich der hochrüstung und der
annäherung der beiden supermächte und
der anfang vom ende des sowjetischen
imperiums und des kalten krieges man hat
ja olaf scholz gestern klare kante
gezeigt hat bestimmte maßnahmen
angekündigt auch zusammen mit seinen
beiden koalitionspartner in der
ampelkoalition
ich möchte trotzdem gern noch einmal auf
die das verhältnis eben was vielleicht
auch deutschland russland da in diesem
bereich betrifft es gibt ja auch nach
wie vor die meinung dass es in den
letzten jahren in den letzten
jahrzehnten durchaus versäumnisse
gegeben hat beispielsweise auch im
verhältnis wladimir putin real zu
betrachten ist dass wir hatten eine
bundeskanzlerin aus ostdeutschland kann
dass damit etwas zu tun haben ist man in
ostdeutschland weniger sozusagen
differenziert also jetzt bei in der
politik beispielsweise in bezug auf
russland wenn sie unsere kanzlerin
nehmen würde ich sagen überhaupt nicht
da mögen sich auch bei der kanzlerin
seinerzeit russland politische defizite
oder auch versäumnisse gewesen sein
beispielsweise die die blauäugigkeit
kann man anfassen muss man sagen es
energiepolitisch weiterhin in diese
abhängigkeit zu geben oder schlicht wird
die tatsache 2011 das unter dieser
kanzlerin und sie hat immerhin
richtlinienkompetenz sie mit der fdp die
jetzt auch in der regierung ist die
bundeswehr wehrpflicht auch abschafft
das sind sicher falsche entscheidungen
gewesen die sich jetzt herausstellt aber
sie hat sich in vielerlei hinsicht nicht
zuletzt auch aufgrund ihrer russland
expertise und ihrer sprachkenntnisse
nämlich mit putin auch auf augenhöhe
entweder auf deutsch und auf russisch
unterhalten zu können das ist
psychologisch sehr wichtig auch wichtige
lokale regionale kompetenz gehabt und
sie wusste stets natürlich wenn sie in
moskau war mit wem sie spricht sie ist
ddr sozialisiert sie hat ein land in der
transformation erlebt was russland nach
1990 auch der fall gewesen ist und dass
sie schon mal ganz andere
ausgangsposition und sie hat auch sehr
wohl auch in dieser hinsicht eine
russland politik mit blick auch auf
verständigung einerseits auf der anderen
seite aber auch immer wieder deutlich
gemacht wenn es probleme gab entschieden
beispielsweise menschen
menschenrechtsbereich auch entschieden
dagegen auch deutliche worte an zu
anzubringen was ist eigentlich das
besondere an diesem deutsch russischen
verhältnis dass es uns manchmal in der
vergangenheit so schwer gemacht hat auch
sehr klar gegenüber russland aufzutreten
denke beispielsweise ja auch an
veranstaltungen und auch die nord stream
zwei unterstützung aus mecklenburg
vorpommern
von manuela schwesig der dort sich
ministerpräsidentin also ich glaube das
besondere in diesem ich möchte als
deutsch russisches jahrhundert
bezeichnen vom vorabend des ersten
weltkriegs im grunde bis in die
gegenwart ist es gibt noch beim der
verhalten keine länder weltweit deren
verhältnis so stark so intensiv
einerseits durch revolution und umbruch
terror und gewalt aber auch annäherung
und abgrenzung oder abgrenzung und
zusammenarbeit geprägt ist das werden
sie schwerlich glaube ich auch wenn sie
die ganze europäische staatenwelt sich
auch angucken mit blick auf bilaterale
verhältnis zu russland so nicht
vorfinden und natürlich mit blick auf
das was jetzt im augenblick geschieht
und auch mitunter auch zögerliche
haltung der deutschen oder auch die
bereitschaft vermittler sein zu wollen
die handeln sehr stark natürlich auch
unter dem gesichtspunkt der gemeinsamen
gewalt und des terrors dem man unter
anderem erfahren hat das ist der zweite
weltkrieg beispielsweise der hier für
beide seiten für diese für russland bis
zum heutigen tage wladimir putin betont
es jetzt ja auch immer wieder auch bei
seinen reden in der geschichtspolitische
argumentiert aber auch für die deutschen
die deutschen haben nach 1990 angefangen
mit helmut kohl aber dann auch mit
schröder und mit merkel immer wieder
auch im blick haben müssen vorsichtig zu
agieren gegenüber russland die russen
aber auch ernst zu nehmen
sicherheitsbedürfnisse zu
berücksichtigen dass auch in richtung
westen zu kommunizieren aber sie mussten
auch immer die osteuropäer im blick
behalten die baltischen staaten
beispielsweise polen ungarn die
osteuropäer die ebenfalls teil der
deutschen geschichte sind und die man
nicht ohne weiteres verprellen konnte in
dieser politik und in dieser zeit genau
darüber reden wir nachher nochmal weiter
stefan kreutzberger von der universität
in rostock erst mal vielen dank so weit
für ihre einschätzung